ce soir olivier avant que tu fasses
baffie dans l'oreillette je voulais tu
te faire un beau cadeau tu étais quel
genre d'élève au collège moyens tendance
molle endossement je t'ai demandé de
parler de toi c'était pas vrai je t'ai
pas une flèche mais ça l'est parce que
moi on m'a raconté que tu faisais partie
des beaux gosses du collège peut-être
comparativement aux autres dont le
physique était davantage altérer ses
fans faisaient chavirer plus d'un coeur
à on a été contacté par une personne
bah ouais hein si je te montre cette
photo regarde cette photo c'est quoi ça
le collège saint michel
si vous souhaitez j'étais dans quelle
ville
bruxelles bruxelles donc bruxelles bien
sûr on ne sait pas si je tente
maintenant quand c'est cette photo est
ce que tu te rappelles delphine non si
je te dis nathalie nat nathalie c'est
possible certainement mais ça remonte à
loin tout ça nathalie ça fait plus de 40
ans qu'elle vit avec un regret oui mais
tu vois et nathalie elle est là pour toi
ce soir nathalie qui était à l'école
[Applaudissements]
diable m
nathalie est ce que tu es reconnaît
olivier mais disons que ça fait un
moment mais oui je croise par rapport à
la photo il sans doute et à l'ouïe les
yeux la talus vous êtes vous vouliez
absolument tenir ce soir pour voir
olivier oui pourquoi
ben ça fait 40 ans que j'attends de 40
n'aura tenu qu'à un saut de chatons de
ce moment là quoi donc je suis super
content de le voir vous voulez
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec olivier bas en fait je sais pas si
tu te souviens d'une soirée donc chez
nicolas brisson
on était à saint nicolas brault sont
bons il ya toujours des noms comme ça
nous on était en premier
donc c'était soirée bout d'accord voilà
et j'étais avec ma copine emilie et je
savais que tu serais là cette soirée là
et je te cache pas que maje et amoureuse
de toi voilà est arrivé le moment où il
ya eu la musique pour le slow donc
c'était la musique digne au film top gun
d'accord maillebois the way dire ouais
voilà c'est juin exactement et donc tu
es venu vert noir et je me suis dit ça y
est c'est dans la poche et un manque de
bol taoïste et ma copine et munichois
hammers
mais on avec l année là vous en 12 ans
oui c'est le ticket est aujourd'hui
j'aimerais qu'on revit ce moment et que
tu te rattrape olivier et tu le fasses
leçon
la nuit nathalie lussier je danse très
mal ils n'ont pas changé c'est les mêmes
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien court jeudi matin l'invité et
voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
oui vous souhaitez chasse a beaucoup
maintenant l'idée olivier est ce que
t'as kiffé haut niveau c'est une
expérience à dire parce que je n'ai plus
et je veux que j'ai pu beaucoup de
mémoire faut pas m'en vouloir nathalie
olivier je me souviens plus beaucoup je
me suis a pas vraiment de toi mais
j'imagine que forcément bien sûr on
s'est connu à ce moment là mais c'est
pas grave si une mousse l'eau mais ce
dernier visiblement va rendre partir bas
je veux bien bref à lézignan allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci merci merci merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir est à découvrir ci dessous
[Applaudissements]
verdir son garçon de non dit la vérité
ça me l'a jamais dit non ça très bien
comment j'ai beaucoup c'est un peu
unique hôtel de paris accueille ben si
c'est un piège alors je comprends mieux
mais c'était parce que table regarde
elle s'est beaucoup préparé avant que tu
l'avoir gardes pour toi spécialement oui
bien sûr un impact moi qui voulais
parler puis ça revient très fort ce jure
que c'est vrai suivent la mode tout le
temps alors c'est l'ennemi d'oiseaux
souillés brass band ce type si ça
revient très très fort vous le dos à dos
sur des bras jeu attendez j'ai vraiment
commencé à douter fameusement de ma
mémoire
rien ne me rappelais et rien ça t'as
fait ça devait plaisir